[Música]
bienvenidos a la nueva emisión de
reporteros gracias por estar con
nosotros comenzamos
termina la era merkel la cancillera
alemana deja su puesto después de 16
años en el poder y de estabilidad angela
merkel se caracterizó por no generar
conflicto ni divisiones innecesarias en
esta emisión de reporteros les traemos
el legado que dejó atrás el manejo de
tres crisis la primera el gran reto la
crisis financiera de 2008 su rigurosidad
generó odios y aplausos su segundo reto
fue la crisis migratoria de 2015 cientos
de miles de sirios llegaron a europa
huyendo de la guerra y alemania le dio
asilo a más de un millón restaurando la
imagen del país en el extranjero su
tercer reto ya en su cuarto y último
mandato fue la crisis sanitaria que
trajo el coi 19 y por consiguiente las
medidas excepcionales en el siguiente
reportero les contamos paso a paso lo
que significó para el país la gestión
que hizo merkel en estas etapas aquí la
historia
[Música]
berlín 5 de octubre de 2008 en medio de
la tormenta por la crisis financiera la
canciller alemana angela merkel busca
tranquilizar a la población
las economías de los alemanes están
seguras el gobierno alemán lo garantiza
el país está al borde de la recesión
angela merkel está en el poder desde
hace tres años
enfrenta su primer gran reto
este año mattis mengelle acababa de
retomar las riendas de la empresa
familiar
una pyme especializada en la fabricación
de turbinas heredada de padre a hijo
desde hace tres generaciones
este nuestro pan de cada día máquinas
industriales ya no podemos con las
clásicas las máquinas han estado
inactivas desde hace unos meses la
quiebra del banco lehman brothers en
eeuu sumió a los mercados financieros y
a la economía mundial en una gran
incógnita en alemania se desbloquean dos
planes de reactivación
estábamos muy preocupados que jefe de
empresa no se inquieta cuando los
pedidos se detienen pero el solo hecho
de saber que había ayudas importantes
disponibles en caso de problemas nos
ayuda a dormir mejor
aquí nadie fue despedido los negocios se
retomaron
ella
pudo haber sido mucho peor este año la
cuota de popularidad de angela merkel
dio un salto la señora merkel se mantuvo
muy soberana
pero confianza con una política muy
razonada fue realmente en ese momento
cuando la que era todavía considerada
como la hija de helmut kohl se convirtió
en una mujer dictada por un lado era muy
respetada a nivel internacional pero al
mismo tiempo sabía mostrarse firme sin
embargo al otro lado del continente en
grecia la situación se degenera cuando
uno lo piensa son imágenes realmente
duras la crisis financiera se transforma
en una crisis de la deuda arrastrando
consigo a todo un país que termina
odiando a la rigurosa canciller grecia
se hunde amenazando con hacer estallar
el euro la moneda única europea
pero angela merkel la canciller del país
más poderoso de europa se mantendrá
firme con atenas
y siempre lo hemos dicho grecia no
tocará un céntimo a menos de que se
hagan esfuerzos
durante más de 10 años grecia se ve
obligada a reducir drásticamente sus
gastos públicos los salarios y las
jubilaciones disminuyen la pobreza se
dispara actualmente cerca del 35 por
ciento de la población todavía vive por
debajo del umbral de pobreza
estoy contenta de que exista
porque necesito comida y no tengo dinero
para comprar
esta ong se fundó en 2008 el año en el
que janis cal y mary's perdió su trabajo
nunca más volvió a encontrar uno
sé lo que es estar en una situación así
así que trato de aportar un poco de
solidaridad tal como ellos lo hacían
reunir y
en 2015 impulsado por la rabia de los
griegos es elegido un gobierno de
izquierda para rechazar los planes de
austeridad que se multiplican pero
berlín amenaza con excluir a grecia de
la zona euro alexis tsipras el primer
ministro griego multiplica las
conversaciones con angela merkel la
recuerda como una mujer de una gran
inteligencia sensible pero intransigente
estaba muy preocupada por las
consecuencias de la hostería para la
población pero también consideraba que
era necesario pasar por ahí
como un mal indispensable una especie de
purgatorio necesario para consolidar las
zonas de país
era un enfoque que se podría calificar
como protesta no ciertamente ligado a
los valores bajo los cuales ella misma
creció y evolucionó y angela merkel
sorda ante el sufrimiento del pueblo
griego
aún así resultará ser mucho más
caritativa unos meses después
lo lograremos tal como hemos logrado
muchas cosas anteriormente
[Música]
la cuestión migratoria que es de lo que
se quebrará será el vínculo que os une a
los derechos cívicos universales
en el verano de 2015 cientos de miles de
sirios que huyen de la guerra se
amontonan ante las puertas del
continente alemania otorga asilo
político a más de un millón de sirios
mohamad yasin se instala con su familia
en luz dixel no muy lejos de berlín
el ingeniero naval trabaja actualmente
en las construcciones alemanas
chao
ahora sí no
y
juntos recorrieron la ruta de los
balcanes antes de llegar a alemania
donde fueron acogidos en un centro para
refugiados
y
la acogida fue cálida y bondadosa pero
muy pronto la familia se enfrenta a otra
realidad
como un día que estaba en el
supermercado con mi hija un hombre se me
acercó y me dijo mujer con velo de miel
hay gente muy mal aquí pero también hay
muchas personas que han sido muy amables
de noche
[Música]
la política migratoria de angela merkel
restaura la imagen de alemania en el
extranjero pero favorece la ascensión de
un pequeño partido creado durante la
crisis financiera alternativa para
alemania
[Música]
en
esto
[Música]
en 2015 el partido se posiciona en una
estricta línea anti refugiados angela
merkel se convierte en su peor enemigo
[Música]
2015 es totalmente su culto y ya no
tenía derecho a hacer eso quiere que le
diga cómo será merkel a la historia para
mí
la señora merkel es una criminal
en 2017 la fed entra al parlamento
federal es la primera vez que un partido
de extrema derecha forma parte del
bundestag desde el final de la segunda
guerra mundial entre sus miembros más
radicales están ya que destino
alternativo para alemania es el único
verdadero partido de posición en este
país sólo a efe detienen la voz de la
razón queremos preservar la identidad de
alemania no hay nada de inmoral en eso
es lo más normal del mundo
en berlín thomas de mazière es entonces
el ministro del interior durante diez
años fue uno de los colaboradores más
cercanos de la canciller
fue en ese momento cuando empezamos a
sentir mucha agresividad en las calles
y eso afectó mucho a merkel
y sin embargo según él la canciller
nunca se arrepintió de su decisión
y se suele decir que merkel abrió las
fronteras de alemania pero eso no es del
todo cierto simplemente se negó a
cerrarla hay una gran diferencia el
hecho de que ella creció en alemania el
este jugó un papel importante
cristian ha estado rodeado de muros de
alambre de púas y no quería volver a
construir nuevos muros
en 2018 angela merkel anuncia que su
cuarto mandato será el último su tasa de
popularidad es muy baja cuando se
anuncia una nueva crisis en china el
kobe 19 se propaga por el mundo entero y
un primer caso es detectado en alemania
en el mes de enero merkel científica de
formación presidente del peligro
en 2020 padecimos un evento que el mundo
nos esperaba
un virus desconocido al momento de
nuestras vidas y nuestros
en la frontera franco-alemana el
hospital de homburg que se prepara para
lo peor
philip le père y su equipo son los
encargados de montar una estación kobe
[Música]
este es el hombre que garantizó que todo
funcionará como debe ser un función
disfuncional durante la primavera de
2020 alemania salió relativamente bien
librada de la primera ola mortal de la
pandemia pero no muy lejos de ahí en
model el virus causó estragos el
hospital recibió a seis pacientes
franceses con insuficiencias
respiratorias en un mismo día
el primero de esos pacientes franceses
fue recibido en esta habitación
y sus pacientes estaban en coma
y hay que destacar el trabajo de los
colegas franceses quienes realmente
escogieron bien a estos pacientes desde
un punto de vista médico
porque se trataba de pacientes muy
enfermos pero que tenían una posibilidad
muy realista de lograrlo
[Música]
entre esos pacientes curados en alemania
está danzón con jets ni
él y su mujer nos reciben en su casa en
santa vol
ella fue la que me levantó la primera
vez
durante meses el personal del hospital
envió de manera regular fotos y vídeos
christina con youzhny realizó cada
semana varios viajes de ida y vuelta
para ir a visitarlo le cocino platos
calientes que ellos recalentaban
y era muy bueno porque los de bieber nos
llegaban con una pequeña servilleta como
en un restaurante
francamente fue
les debemos todo lo salvaron dos veces y
tuve suerte de haber sido transferido a
alemania eso es seguro
competimos con soy consciente de eso
y le agradezco a toda la clínica a todo
el personal y también al sistema
establecido por merkel le agradezco
personalmente
durante el verano de 2020 junto con
emmanuel macrón angela merkel se
concentra en el paciente europeo
anuncian la creación de un plan de
solidaridad de 750 mil millones de euros
ante una situación excepcional
son necesarias medidas excepciones
la canciller que nunca fue una europea
de corazón según shanghai gm acepta por
primera vez pagar por los demás la
potencia no es solamente un asunto
militar un giro inesperado pero tardío
según este especialista en temas
europeos
es verdad que en que la educación
terminó por poder ser europeo en fin es
decir que al final se da cuenta de que
en el fondo si europa sky o si por
ejemplo el euro de sangre si eso podría
perjudicar a alguien pero es únicamente
porque a su podría perjudicar alemania y
finalmente se vuelve europea un deseo
por preservar a toda costa los intereses
alemanes lo cual tal vez explica la
longevidad de esta canciller
aunque sus detractores la acusan de ser
una mujer sin una gran visión le dio 16
años de estabilidad a una nación a la
que no le gusta mucho el cambio aún hoy
es la personalidad política preferida de
los alemanes
siempre le dio a los alemanes la
sensación de estar cien gobernados y que
no los engañaría a
la señora merkel así ella misma sus
compras en el supermercado y no lo hace
para mandarle una señal a lo que ella
realmente es así
y esa manera que tiene de ser normal en
el ejercicio del poder le ha permitido
mantenerse a largo plazo
creo que ese es uno de los secretos de
su longevidad
uno de los muchos secretos de esta
canciller que los alemanes han seguido
llamando muti si bien conquistó el
título de la mujer más poderosa del
mundo
en el pico de su gloria angela merkel
abandona el poder por voluntad propia y
los alemanes se preparan para un gran
salto hacia lo desconocido
gracias por acompañarnos en esta emisión
de reporteros recuerde que puede
ingresar a nuestra página web más 24
punto com para ver esta emisión y las
anteriores hasta la próxima semana
[Música]